they like you know you gonna be a top 20
whatever whatever
so um i had great workouts great
meetings people you know calling me all
the way up until the draft date so when
they get there and it's like all right
i'm still waiting still waiting it's
like
the way i was waiting for that long it's
like
they gonna pay for that for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
so first question is
from aot mckitren jersey your path you
finally got now to your first nba media
training camp what does it feel like
oh it's still surreal um i don't think
i've taken it yet like i feel like once
you get you know to this level it's like
you got so much more
that you want to do and accomplish it's
like you can't really you know take us
take a step back and be like all right i
made it
i think patience is the first word that
comes to mind for you
last season you had to be patient to
finally start playing uh now what is it
what is it where patience mean to you um
patience sacrifice those are two words
i've been you know raised up on so
i'm just not new something nothing that
you know kind of rattled me um
you know it's hard when you finally get
to a point and
stuff just randomly happened that you
had no clue of or no control over so
that's probably the hard part um
understanding that but you know now it's
like a next step and
try to take control of your journey
we've always seen you be real calm and
cool
um i think it's only been a few times
i've actually seen you show that emotion
what makes you so calm out there and
stay even killed yeah um i don't know
how i level it out honestly because
on the court it's like
it's all the goal
that's like whatever is whatever but my
face never kind of changed but my
attitude is like it's definitely you
know killed at all times i think the
only times we've seen you with that
emotion was for st patrick's a couple
years ago if you remember the scene was
crazy
the crowd was going really nuts and i
saw that emotionally you turned to the
crowd it was very like animated and
whatnot you know what was that game like
yeah just being back you know where it
kind of all started uh in jersey my
whole all my family from jersey
a lot of them still live there so being
at where it's saw started from
being that i was coming back
playing against a team that's in in the
middle of jersey so
[Music]
the crowd was crazy they talking trash
that i haven't been like that a long
time like just you know emotion like
that but
it was like they were so on the court
like you could hear everything so when
i'm hearing everything just mainly from
this side of this crowd so
he made a couple shots just like why
like why are you not talking like so
that's all it was it was it was
definitely a fun experience though yeah
you've uh mentioned some of the some
players that you really like model your
game after i look up to and it seems
like cp is like a first you know chris
paul and what is it you take from him
and what is your relationship uh like oh
what i take from um just the way he can
balance passion and scoring i never felt
like i was a scorn or a pass first i
feel like i could do a mix of both at a
high level so
that's one person i really see that you
know could mix both and still be
effective
so just watching him throughout the
years all the whole time i grew up you
know somebody i kind of seen myself
similar to
not jumping over the rim not doing all
that but he always is one of the best
players on the floor so that's something
i look up to and we had a great
relationship ever since
we played their team in eighth grade and
he was there and we lost and i actually
had a good game but you know he he kind
of respected my game and he seen me
crying and he
he's like show me um
he said show me somebody who liked
losing and i'll show you a loser
that's something he says and that's what
he told me after the game so
he just had a good relationship ever
since then yeah what is your what is
your leadership style like if you can
describe it
i i want to win at all at all costs i
feel like i have a good understanding of
people and my teammates i always had a
great relationship with everybody so
um i know how to you know talk to
certain people a certain way i know who
could take you know yelling and who
can't so
um
everything i do is kind of based off win
it so whatever i say come from a good
heart my team know that
i don't really do too much yelling
but you know when i say something it's
mutual respect so did you i mean even
draft night i wanted to ask you about
like what was that night like in the
sense of being so waiting so long we
talked about patients earlier and
waiting to hear your name and that
relief that came out your face but like
what was the first thing that popped in
your mind after you finally heard your
name it's like all right it was hard
honestly because you know when i came
out of college you never protected
lottery did this and that all the way up
into the combine they like you know you
gonna be a top 20 whatever whatever
so um i had great workouts great
meetings people you know calling me all
the way up until the draft date so when
they get there and it's like all right
i'm still waiting still waiting it's
like
the way i was waiting for that long it's
like
you know they gonna pay for that they
don't pay for that for sure yeah did you
i mean i know that the chip on your
shoulder i'm sure is huge now we're
coming to this season and the goals that
you guys set out for yourself what do
you have stood out to accomplish let's
just say work a year year one
i don't know it's so much up in the air
um i i just wanna you know going to
practice the next day and just you know
dominate
i feel like i got a lot of show
stuff that
i haven't shown yet that i feel like i
show all the time on
outside of the camera so i'm just ready
for practice man that's it
i'm ready for the next practice training
camp and then after that the next
practice so that's all my mind set on
the games i haven't even
experienced the game so i don't know
what it's like so
i'm not really worried about that right
now yeah did you feel like you showed a
good
uh arsenal of your game in summer league
some really was like really exciting to
see how like you running the offense you
and jalen the way you guys kind of
handled things together the game-winning
shot you had um like where do you think
you're able to show somebody this past
oh i don't feel like i showed it a
little bit
nothing
to what i think i can so i get better
off playing 515 and stuff like that so
that's kind of how i develop a rhythm
i've been playing a lot of five and five
after the summer league so i feel like
i'm in a great rhythm right now
i did i
uh i think i'd give myself a c c plus
for what i did
you have a very strong
fan base i don't know if you're aware of
that
but they'll do anything for you oh and
what is it like just having that support
system on fans that really ride with you
constantly and it's like yo if we
if they see a top 10 of point guards if
they see a list and it's like oh where's
sharif it's quickly being asked where's
reefer but they really right for you
what is that like it's dope um
it's it's great to have a support staff
outside
you know of your of your family and
anything i i see this the same stuff you
see um i mean
they they always got my back when uh
somebody say something that's not true
or whatever case may be they always the
first one to respond so you know i'm
super thankful for them for sure if
somebody asks you right now
which one you got to claim is it jersey
or is it in atlanta
and why too
i had to go both
i feel like i'm from
my roots uh you know my heart my blood
isn't in new jersey but
you know i grew up in in georgia so i
always gonna have to you know tie the
tired of both of them but
definitely yeah i probably say jersey i
love atlanta though i'm still
i grew up here you know atl that's what
i got in my jersey so yeah that's who
you rocking with
[Music]
you